never hurts to get a bit more practice
so this is problem number five from the
normal distribution chapter from
ck12.org
ap statistics flexbook so they're saying
the 2007 ap statistics examination
scores were not
normally distributed with a mean of 2.8
and a standard deviation of
1.34 they cite some college board stuff
here i didn't copy and paste that what
is the approximate z-score remember
z-score is just how many standard how
how many standard deviations you are
away from the mean what is the
approximate z-score that corresponds to
an exam score of five so we really just
have to figure out this is a pretty
straightforward problem we just need to
figure out how how many standard
deviations is 5 from the mean
well 5 well it's once you just take 5
minus 2.8 right the mean is 2.8 let me
be very clear mean is 2.8 they give us
that didn't even have to calculate it
right so the mean is 2.8 so 5 minus 2.8
is equal to 2.2 so we're 2.2 above the
mean and if we want that in terms of
standard deviations we just divide by
our standard deviation we divide by 1.34
1.34 divide by 1.34
i'll take out the calculator for this
so we have 2.2
divided by 1.34
is equal to 1.64
so this is this is equal to 1.64
and that's choice c so this was actually
very straightforward we just have to see
how far away we are from the mean if we
get a score of five
which hopefully you will get if you're
taking the ap statistics exam after
watching these videos and then you
divide by the standard deviation to say
how many standard deviations away from
the mean is the score of five it's 1.64
i think the only tricky thing here might
have been you might have been tempted
to pick choice e which says a z score
cannot be calculated because the
distribution is not normal and i think
the reason why you might have had that
temptation is because we've been using z
scores within the context of a normal
distribution
but a z-score literally just means how
many standard deviations you are away
from the mean it could be it could apply
to any distribution because that you can
calculate a mean and a standard
deviation 4. so e is not the correct
answer a z-score can apply to a
non-normal distribution so the answer is
c and i guess that's a good point of
clarification to get out of the way
i thought i would do two problems in
this video just because that one was
pretty short so problem number six the
heights of fifth grade boys in the
united states is approximately normally
distributed that's good to know
with the mean height of
143.5 centimeters so it's a mean of
143.5 centimeters and a standard a
standard deviation
of about 7.1 centimeters standard
deviation of 7.1
centimeters what is the probability that
a randomly chosen fifth grade boy would
be taller than 157.7
centimeters so let's just draw out this
distribution like we've done in a bunch
of problems so far
they're just asking us one question so
we can
mark this distribution up a good bit
let's say that's our distribution
and the mean here
the mean they told us is 143.5
they're asking us taller than 157.7 so
we're going the upwards direction so one
standard deviation above the mean will
take us
right there and we just have to add 7.1
to this number right here we're going up
by 7.1 so 143.5 plus 7.1 is what 150.6
150.26 that's one standard deviation if
we were to go another standard deviation
we go 7.1 more with 7.1 plus 150.6 it's
which just happens to be is the exact
number they ask for they're asking for
heights the probability of getting a
height a lot higher than that so they
want to know what's the probability that
we fall under this area right here or
essentially more than two standard
deviations from the mean or above two
standard deviations we can't count this
left tail right there so we can use the
empirical rule
we can use the empirical rule if we do
our standard deviations to the left
that's one standard deviation two
standard deviations we know what this
whole area is the area let me pick a
different color
so that i don't so we know what this
we know what this area is the area
within two standard deviation the
empirical rule tells us so even better
the 68
99.7 rule tells us that this area
because it's within two standard
deviations is
95 percent
or 0.95 or it's 95 of the area under the
normal distribution
which tells us that what's left over
this tail that we care about and this
left tail right here has to make up the
rest of it or 5
so those two combined have to be five
percent and these are symmetrical we've
done this before this is actually a
little redundant from other problems
we've done but if these are added
combined five percent and they're the
same then each of these are two and a
half percent
each of these are two and a half percent
so to the answer the question what is
the probability that a randomly chosen
fifth grade boy would be taller than
157.7 centimeters well that's literally
just the area under this right green
part maybe i'll do it in a different
color this magenta part that i'm
coloring right now that's just that area
and we just figured out it's 2.5 so
there's a two and a half percent chance
we'd randomly find a fifth grade boy
who's taller than
157.7 centimeters assuming this is the
mean the standard deviation and we are
dealing with a normal distribution